the NHS budget has been increased to
record levels to deal with the pandemic
and today I'm asking the NHS to join all
public services in tackling waste and
inefficiency we want Scandinavian
quality alongside Singaporean efficiency
both better outcomes for citizens
at her value for taxpayers
that does not mean asking people on the
front line often exhausted and burned
out to work harder which would not be
possible or fair but it does mean asking
challenging questions about how to
reform all our public services for the
better
so with respect to the NHS
I've asked former Health secretary and
chair of the Norfolk and Waverley
integrated care system Patricia Hewitt
to help me and the health secretary
achieve that by advising us on how to
make sure the new integrated care boards
the
[Music]
operate efficiently and with appropriate
autonomy and accountability
I've also had discussions with NHS
England
about the inflationary pressures on
their budgets I recognize that
efficiency savings alone will not be
enough to deliver the services we all
need so because of difficult decisions
taken elsewhere today I will increase
the NHS budget in each of the next two
years by 3.3 billion pounds
the chief executor of the NHS Amanda
Pritchard has said that this should
provide sufficient funding for the NHS
to fulfill its key priorities
she said it shows the government is
serious about its commitment to
prioritize our NHS
3.3 billion for the NHS 4.7 billion
pounds for social care a record 8
billion pounds package for our Health
and Care system that is a conservative
government putting the NHS first
and Mr Speaker
chess
and schools in Scotland the NHS and
schools in Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland face equivalent pressures so the
Barnet consequentials of today's
decisions mean an extra 1.5 billion
pounds for the Scottish government 1.2
billion pounds for the Welsh government
650 million pounds for the Northern
Ireland executive that is more resources
for the schools and hospitals in our
devolved Nations next year the year
after and every year thereafter
[Music]